excuse me mr bande dunn yes sir yes yes
what do you feel about child molesters
who are let free but the person who's
defending their child who shot at him
doesn't get out of jail uh and there's
no bail what do you think on that what
do you know i think that's a very
specific case and it reminds me a lot of
the case of cain velasquez and i think
in most cases attempted murder
is okay and i look on the camera and i
do this
in most cases you said in most cases in
most cases okay in five four three two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
we have the domestic violence king yeah
patricia i looked at nick i thought it
was me
i'm talking about you man you said yeah
so you yeah
he looked at you like yeah this fool
does beat his wife if the lady talks
back you get the [ __ ] knuckles dude
sean connery minnie junior dude that's
my name i'm sean connery jr these are
all jokes by the way for people who are
just listening not for patrick
absolutely
it's a lifestyle right
yeah it's a lifestyle i believe in it
and then we have nick the [ __ ] tan
asian ear and asian look at you you're
the same color as the couch you're
sitting on i just delicious and brown i
like really boring colors your band-aid
color yeah
is this
this color
black and white and this is a new shirt
color
it's okay you don't like this shirt no i
like the shirt i'm just talking about
your face though
i'm talking skin color oh my god
literally accurate you know you know
when they made the band-aid i didn't
know that the color of the band-aid is
supposed to be match my skin it's
supposed to match flesh that's perfect
it's only you though
i'm who they thought of it's good it's
pretty good i like it it's a nice
amazing thank you i appreciate it
i'll call you band-aid face now dude
that's really [ __ ] good
dude
so it's been like a crazy [ __ ] month
i feel like the world's exploding we're
all gonna die obviously
in the last
[ __ ] well i guess because we do talk
a lot about mma we have to talk about
cain velasquez quez whoa velazquez
and him just
capping a [ __ ] do you did you
guys hear about the whole story in
general yeah yeah it's what it's it's a
guy that was at his at a daycare at his
mother's run day care center
i think it was like out of a house was
it not a house or something i don't know
i just knows a daycare but anyway so
he i guess he had a history a prior
history of touching children and let's
hire them boom yeah that's the guy like
son we need you working today so he
would just come help out like apparently
that was his role i guess and then he
was molesting kids over 100 times so i
guess i think the investigation they're
doing now is trying to figure out if any
other kids have been abused for sure
what's weird about the the way the
articles were in the beginning was they
were they were vague it was like kane
velasquez shoots
attempted murder at s uh dude that that
molested a relative or something but
it's his son they would always say
relative yeah first they said [ __ ]
peace they said it was the daughter and
then now
the story is is a crackhead writing this
story like what the [ __ ] is going on i
don't know why they were being vague i
think people are just lying i think
people are like they they probably
thought that they had a hunch of what it
was and they were like oh it's denise
and then you know how like media cycles
it just becomes misinformation after a
while because i'm sure they didn't want
to release
like all the details because i know the
police does that like they don't tell
everybody in the public exactly what it
is because they're worried about like
evidence tampering or whatever the case
may be so his son was molested by this
guy over allegedly over 100 times
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah so it was
like
repeat repeatedly you know that i guess
that's what the the little boy said but
um
yeah
it's just like
bro like understandably anybody i think
any parent would understand like what he
did
like dude i thought it was a one-time
thing no and then cain velasquez found
out then went mad yeah and went to go
hunt this [ __ ] so it was a
hundred times oh allegedly over a
hundred times a lot of times
how did they get that number exactly
that's what that's what i think about
all the time they asked the little boy
they they the little boy said it i i
read it he's like easy 100
he has like tick marks that kid can
count dude
maya can't count to [ __ ] ten dude i
think they were saying
i think they were saying that the guy
was trying to help the kids take their
pants off before they go to bed like
their bathroom like that was his role
that he said how is that a how's that
he made up he made up a position well
what's what's so it's that guy's
mother's daycare and she never stepped
in and was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing well they must be it's
probably a [ __ ] up family yeah i mean
like how does she have business who
knows first of all
looks creepy if i went to a daycare and
then the assistant was this crackhead i
would take my kid out immediately you
can't just have older dudes just hanging
around yeah like you have to have some
backstory of like who this person is to
this establishment especially when
you're dealing with kids because you
never know and i want access to the nest
cam footage all over the place i want to
see everything at all times yeah dude
and it's so crazy that this would happen
to a guy like [ __ ] kane velasquez who
has you know
on paper
like he has millions of dollars probably
right
and for something like this to happen to
his kid is just like
so that means everybody everybody this
happens everywhere yeah of course so
crazy even think about it i think we
need to change the system a little bit
because like the so the guy also
he like was arrested but they let him go
that was part of that was part of cain
velasquez's issue was that they they had
him and they let him go or something and
cain was like [ __ ] that i'ma kill this
[ __ ] and like oh [ __ ] dude the
thing is is it i i saw a tweet too where
i think it was ben askren he's like i
don't want to live in a country where
someone can molest your kid get away and
then you go to jail for [ __ ] trying
to kill him and it makes it it's like
he's out on bail ending it's [ __ ] up
who the guy the guy yeah the guy's out
so kane's in jail kane's in jail but
this dude's out and about and the the
[ __ ] i sent you earlier the gofundme
that [ __ ] was crazy too i didn't even
know that but there was people starting
gofundme for the rapist though yeah
that's a loud that's all good help him
get back on his feet so he could touch
once again yeah the u.s criminal justice
system they they handle child molesters
very interestingly like it's i don't
understand what the metrics are and how
they they deal with them but it seems
like they're everywhere i think there
needs to be a law where like certain
situations
like this one for example you can handle
on your own you know what i mean like it
sounds barbaric in wild west but like
doug that's [ __ ] crazy how are you it
was interesting because the judge said
that i mean the reason why kane wasn't
allowed bail is because he is a danger
to society or something right
which
i mean there's like two things right
it's you know you can't take the law
into your own hands you can't go around
shooting people it's understandable but
then i just don't understand why this
child molester is allowed just to walk
free yeah if cain velasquez obviously
you know attempted murder if if that's
the case he is a danger to the community
and i don't think kane's a danger to the
community he's a danger to that guy you
know and he promised he wouldn't he
[ __ ] he promised his fingers and i
was like
he's like hey let me out i'm not going
to kill anything but that was one of the
rationale from the judge was that they
were worried that he would finish the
job that's what they said that's
understandable i could see that from the
judge's perspective because he probably
would probably pick you problems
not judge i'm not i ain't gonna do it we
good i shot his stepdad yeah cuz she did
not hit him bro she saw this
she was like kane what's behind your
back oh you got me
i was gonna kill that [ __ ]
they're all sweet about it and [ __ ] dog
that's crazy i don't think it should be
because it is attempted murder but
like dude considering the circumstances
come on now
i think we should be able to tolerate
some attempted murder and i think this
is the case so too i think attempted
murder and i'm gonna run an office
something ron murder's okay i think
let's be real are running for the mayor
and i want that to be your speech go i'm
like you guys you and i'm running for
the mayor saying i'm gonna
yes sir yes yes what do you feel about
child molesters who are let free but the
person who's defending their child who
shot at him doesn't get out of jail uh
and there's no bail what do you think on
that what do you know i think that's a
very specific case and it reminds me a
lot of the case of cain velasquez and i
think in most cases attempted murder
is okay and i look on the camera and i
do this
in most cases you said in most cases in
most cases okay attempted murder is okay
i think we're good yeah we're good i
feel like in court if you were like yo
that guy like molested my son and i
[ __ ] shot him like oh the judge
should be like
all right like all right you might go to
jail for like 30 days yeah it's like um
you're going to jump
in jail
yeah just go sit there for 30 times go
in the corner give me the phone
think about what you did
figure something out if you guys don't
know who came velasquez is he's a former
ufc heavyweight champion probably
considered one of the best
sure
he had a crazy trilogy with junior dos
santos which was insane yeah
this was during a time of like i feel
like heavyweights were the [ __ ] he's a
very likable guy too very likely he
seems very honorable he seems very like
mild-mannered yeah like he he doesn't
seem like he'd mess with it because i
remember when i first heard the news um
of cain velasquez and my head was i'm
gonna wait to see because i know some
people might like crucify him like
everybody was just shocked that he was
charged with
attempted murder and we were thinking
like hopefully this isn't like any
jon jones
type [ __ ] or like chris benoit type [ __ ]
you know where it's like ccd related but
then you find out that this was the case
and you're like
that's i feel like that's kind of in
line with what a guy like kane velasquez
would do i mean i feel like if somebody
molested my dog i might kill him
honestly we
yeah we're gonna i think attempted
murder is okay yeah if you you hurt
someone's dog attempted murder is okay i
think if you molest someone's dog that's
a fight for sure
somebody's touching a dog's butthole
like that's a fight i'm gonna try to
knock you out yeah like a fish scanner
just touches the bottle
what the [ __ ] yeah
yo dare you bro if you're in a dog park
and this guy's trying to like stick his
finger in your dog's butt that's a fist
we would have to break some arms and
legs i think you know something's gonna
happen another time attempting murder is
okay when someone has a dog and they
poop and they don't pick up the poop
with a bag i think attempted murder is
okay you think so attempted murder
that's extreme yeah cause you should
carry a bag you know your dog's gonna
poop carry a bag with you be prepared a
lot of people do that in la though yeah
and a lot of that's why it needs to stop
that's why we need harsher punishments
for these types of things other than
otherwise what's going to happen so wild
wild west i think we're soft i think
i think
how many years do you think kane is
going to get
i i this is the thing i know i hope the
the what scares me is that because it's
a high-profile case i can see a judge
wanting to make an example so that other
people don't do [ __ ] like this that's
what worries me about the situation
hopefully though like on i i don't know
i don't know how these situations work
but i hope that he doesn't do that much
time but i'm afraid that he will because
like i said high profile you know who is
going to jail though for sure
juicy smoothie yeah did you see the
outburst dog this was funny man dude he
was yelling in court you didn't see the
uppers
oh man it's funny he got barred from the
court you have to understand
how narcissistic this human being is
from the original crime in and of itself
and just to refresh everybody this guy
faked a hate crime
saying that a bunch of white people
brought a noose to him at a subway to
kill him and called him the f word
forgot yeah yeah right uh also said some
racial things yeah yep call him a
nigerian wow right and they tried to
quote unquote hang him and beat him and
they said all this other stuff and
bleach they said they poured bleach oh
and they poured bleach on him which is
so funny because he's lighter than i am
they have so many accessories in this
yeah
there's like so many items of symbolism
that they wanted to do
actually just looks like pat
and somehow
these people who are so extremely racist
they looked at him and they decided to
attack him at a subway at like midnight
yeah the oddest thing ever right and so
if you just to refresh once again it
turns out he hired a bunch of african
dudes
they're personal trainers this is a real
story wasn't he [ __ ] one of them
didn't what are you saying
yeah i think he openly admitted he goes
he's just upset because i broke up with
him whoa so that's what it was all about
yeah
what a dick so he was hooking up with
some of these uh nigerian uh booty
compadres yeah and the personal trainers
i believe they're personal trainers
they decided to go
stage this hate crime which is the
funniest thing ever this is a dave
chappelle sketch yeah and this is a
missed the time during you know the blm
thing and this is some serious [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah so not only does he have like
first of all he was on power which was
like one of the biggest tv shows at the
time he was getting paid a [ __ ] ton but
that wasn't enough he wanted to make
sure people know that he is uh a victim
of a hate crime barter and martyr yep
turns out he lied of course wow and now
he's finally getting sentenced and in
the middle of this court proceeding
this was just like what did he say he's
like if i if i die in jail it is not a
suicide
yeah this is what he said he was like
first of all he's like judge he's like
he's like this with his hands he's like
i respect your decision he's like but i
did not do this that's what he says
first of all and then he go he looks
around he's like i am not suicidal so if
something happens to me like i'm not
suicidal why are you [ __ ] just laying
back smoking yeah bro
that high profile bro no one's trying to
kill you like that yeah you have no
secret information anybody wants to know
what the [ __ ] are you doing
what if he ends up in this similar
situation like absolutely's acting like
he's jeffrey epstein like he's got
government secrets dude uh all right i
have no secrets i saw a comment that
said man just serve your 150 days shut
the [ __ ] up that's all yes
i don't know but it's it's not a long
sentence
that's [ __ ] he should go for like 10
years i think he's he definitely has
some type of mental issue because he
thinks that he's that important that's
that's narcissism to the [ __ ] he
literally thinks that he's so important
that when he goes to jail somebody's
going to murder him he doesn't even
understand suicide jeffrey epstein got
murdered because he had specific
information to high-profile human beings
yeah right you
staged a hate crime with a bunch of
africans yeah like that doesn't make any
sense it's like it's kind of the same
dude if anything was gonna happen to him
he's gonna get like the cosby treatment
people throw pudding in his face that's
about it yeah right you know
he might get beat up in jail he might
get beaten funny dude
my lovely genius farts thank you for
keeping this podcast sponsored by
clicking on the links of our sponsors so
we are here to talk about purple my
friends i love me a purple mattress
listen long time sponsor once again and
the only reason why is because i will
put my purple mattress up against
anybody else's mattress
at any time
the best sleep i've ever had in my life
you could even ask my lady she says my
mood is better
she says when i sleep i sleep sound i
don't wake up in the middle of the night
and it's unlike any memory foam i've
ever had they have something called a
gel
flex grid purple mattress bounce back as
you move and as you shift because we all
do that stuff at the end of the day if
you don't have a purple you are missing
out getting a great night's sleep starts
with having a great mattress get a
purple mattress go to purple.com
brain 10 and use code brain 10 for a
limited time you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more that's purple.com
brainted code brain 10 for 10 off any
order of 200 or more purple.com brain 10
promo code brain 10 terms apply
but the outburst was funny it's like
dude why like no one
was everybody just looking puzzled like
i respect your decisions
it's just you just see him but it's it's
like it's quiet in the courtroom and
that's a wild thing to say to a judge i
respect your decision of you making me
go to jail for 150 days
he's like buy and do this
i'm not suicidal just letting everybody
know he's still claiming he did yeah and
150 days in jail listen you'll be fine
yeah that's nothing i don't know if it
is 150 days exactly i just that was what
the comment said but that [ __ ] was funny
as [ __ ] i think it was you're right it
was all it was only about like four or
five months or so yeah it's not like a
super super long time and i don't think
he's going to go into the hardcore
hardcore prison
like he's not going to go into you know
what's it called you know the [ __ ] that
we see on [ __ ] tv it's gonna be one
of those satellite prisons where he's
protected and [ __ ] he'll be fine dude
he'll be right
dude
i did not kill myself i didn't kill
myself i am not suicidal
and you did it all theatrical and [ __ ]
too dude yeah it was shakespeare's
absurd she just walked off and was like
that was good she was like nailed it
not on a hit list dude you're all right
you know no one's trying to get you yeah
the world doesn't say man the whole
[ __ ] you dude i heard all the
fighters are fighting in you that are
ukrainian like the kush gold brothers
fighting
yeah they're out there oh man i think
we're gonna go into world war i hope
dude oh no we're not we're too we're
gonna get drafted i do not [ __ ] that
dude yeah i i what i hate too is like
how like all of a sudden like uh the
media is trying to like
it's kind of like the iraq war they're
trying to build up this like fervor and
hatred towards russia trying to get
people on board they're trying to get
people on board i just saw something uh
beam or like a thing on instagram where
like ron swanson from [ __ ] parks and
rec and some other stupid [ __ ] are like
saying [ __ ] you to putin like there's
like an award show and they're like they
lead it off by like flipping the bird of
putin like okay you're hard to go pick
up a rifle and go to ukraine you [ __ ]
idiots
like get the [ __ ] out of here oh you
flipped off on camera like you're a
[ __ ] dude yeah you can't do that [ __ ]
bro you're a [ __ ] the best person
we still got netflix no like russia
doesn't have netflix bro but you know
they just legalized everything they'd
legalize piracy now which russia russia
is kind of like they're kind of like
just [ __ ] steal it dawg wow
why are you legalizing this like steal
this [ __ ] did you see the girl who wrote
the poem to putin
what oh
no
she's a stupid [ __ ] she lives in echo
park or highland park 100 i [ __ ] love
this girl
so [ __ ] much so out of touch is that
crazy how out of touch we are i was
putin's mother you're not your world
would be filled with love
wow
i i think your husband hates you whoever
you are like three years ago she saw
what gal gadot
saying that off-key song and she saved
the world now i'm gonna do my poem i
think that [ __ ] thinks she's so
important that because she's hot she is
like a good-looking girl but she's so
that's like out of touch hot girl
syndrome or you are like no one has been
honest with you ever in your life
but you we will be honest with you
you're a [ __ ] idiot dude shut the
[ __ ] up
said her to you crazy use real soap and
throw away the crystals [ __ ]
what do you think she smells like [ __ ]
you stink what kind of essential oil
she's like probably rubs [ __ ] time on
her armpits and [ __ ] like
deal like
from the store and like [ __ ] spinach
or some [ __ ] she was like basil i just
want to see pat just like enter her
video shut the [ __ ] up you stink
like what are you talking about
people need to be told this i think more
often than her response to you she's
gonna write you a poem yeah i should
have been your mother yeah she's just
going on this stupid journey
bro you think putin actually watched
that video what are the chances of putin
i bet you he watched it and laughed his
[ __ ] ass
a [ __ ]
stone cold killer stone cold killed like
special opposition
right he doesn't [ __ ] he put poison on
this dude's doorknob that like [ __ ]
destroys your nervous system it was like
an enemy of the state in england he like
that was his [ __ ] thing so like
you're gonna [ __ ] because you hugged
him he's gonna be all right see that's
the thing bro i don't like all these
videos of these celebrities like
flipping off putin because it's like
this dude's back is against the wall he
might say [ __ ] it every our economic
sanctions we're getting [ __ ]
they're crashing the the what's the
currency the ruble yeah they're they're
money that [ __ ] yes and on top of that
he's like [ __ ] i'm trying to press
these bombs
trading potatoes that's what makes me
nervous is like he might just say [ __ ]
it [ __ ] the west because he's pissed
that up also we're pushing russia and
china closer because now russia
doesn't have a place to go so they're
making deals with china they're gonna
introduce their own like their they have
like their own banking system
they're like we're just right and then
also too ukraine like biden and the
laptop remember the laptop was a big
story they're shady dealings in ukraine
for them personally business wise so
it's like and then when you see biden
come out like we gotta defend gas is
going up because you got a defending
democracy has a price like bro you are
so full of [ __ ] how anyone ever believes
that anymore is beyond me wasn't obama
like during this time during his
presidency when uh the same thing was
happening he was like we ain't doing
nothing
he's like he's like
he's like you guys can do all the
sanctions we're not gonna touch this
it's gonna escalate end of the world if
they get down russia i'm just so serious
what happened if trump was president i
wonder what he would be saying right now
oh yeah i think about that too it would
just be [ __ ] hilarious though do you
think he would he would egg
or do you think he'd fly over there
i don't know dude
trump was wild bro too wild boy he was
like
you're a [ __ ] putin suck my dick
they were kind of cool though they were
like they met a couple times yeah i
think they're like best friends they're
buds yeah they're buds do that putin
your [ __ ] wow you're a [ __ ]
wow he's amazing what about he always
does that [ __ ] he always says wow
because i've been watching a lot of
trump videos lately just because of big
fana i wouldn't say i'm a fan
let's just say that
but he has so many weird uh mannerisms
like he always says wow
funniest thing ever if you see somebody
there's like a compilation of people
interrupting him excuse me excuse me wow
you excuse me excuse me wow you're a
[ __ ]
he's had to get it off he's trying to
get along he's [ __ ] funny dude he
takes [ __ ] from anybody he's a master
communicator yeah he's funny as [ __ ]
dude when you hear him talk you you do
want to like listen to see what he's
going to say you never know what the
[ __ ] he's going to say i stepped into
russia i was like wow there's a bunch of
[ __ ] here bunch of [ __ ] russians wow
excuse me there was a video of him too
talking about like he's like sitting in
front of the white house and he's
talking kind of about how
uh the basically military industrial
complex he's like he's like points to
the white house he's like you see this
place he's like everyone in here wants
me to be at war he's like they make
money off this [ __ ] yeah he's like
everyone in there he's like pointing
he's like they want me to be at war all
the time god and he just says that and
it's like whoa dude i don't think you're
supposed to say that but you hear about
that that uh uh i think she's in
congress mtj
marjorie taylor green you ever heard of
her no she's like super conservative
she's like pretty outspoken but they
just popped her on breaking points for
um
she bought fifteen thousand dollars of
lockheed uh stock
and obviously it's a big military you
know uh company
and she tweets that day that she bought
it she says
if we're going to go to war it's going
to be very profitable
and then it shoots up 20 percent so
everyone's giving her [ __ ] because
they're all tracking
all their uh all the senate members and
on the congress members of how they
buy stocks and they they track it and
they see how much it goes up and usually
every time they buy
sure enough there's a little pump the
rich just keep getting richer dude yeah
dude so it's pretty interesting to see
all these people it just shows that like
we are very
war hungry that is how we make that's a
lot of money i just wanted gas to be
back to [ __ ] four dollars at four
dollars was ridiculous as it was yeah
yeah it needs to be like two dollars
dude 99 cents even arco
that's where we go right now but they
still get you with the 35 percent the 35
cents debit [ __ ] debit fee
[ __ ] but
it still makes you feel better about how
you spend gas but that's even like six
seven dollars in some places
like we're [ __ ] we can't even trust
arco even the weird no-name ones like
the dying the weird dinosaur one or like
like a weird hero where it's like i'm
definitely getting my [ __ ] stole my
identity stolen when i put my card in
here like those are even like 10. i
don't know why mentally when i fill up
at those gas stations i'm like my gas
can run out ten times faster yeah i
think so too yeah i always feel like my
gas goes out way faster when i fill up
at those spots i do too
100 and there's no proof of it but it's
true it's 100 true just feels dirty like
i'm buying dirty gas
to fill my car a hundred and fifty they
don't even give you the cash discount
anymore in some places oh for real yeah
like some places i've seen where some
places still honor the cash discount but
then other places where they usually
honor a discount is just the same as
crap cash and debit price hey brother
freedom saving freedom has a cost
all right
wow what a patriot what a patriot you
know what was good was the what's the uh
the bryce mitchell is that his name the
ufc oh yeah he's like
that's what he said was sickest did you
see him [ __ ] everybody i've been hearing
he got kind of flamed recently before
that because he was on the helwani show
and i guess he said some pretty flagrant
things but helwani took the video down
oh right um i think
he was something about gun rights that
he was kind of going in on
i think he kind of pulled back on that a
little bit and now he's saying things
within the same realm of like political
stuff and policies because i think
his main thing i think that real people
really like about him he goes fighting
is just a small part of my life he goes
this is just armor because you're trying
to be a farmer and a rapper
have you heard his album no i have his
full raps
he needs to be a rapper to be honest
with you better than tyron woodley
what about better than mgk
mgk is actually pretty dope rapper yeah
but so not as good no no no no not as
good and different levels at different
levels bryce mitchell though like he's
not bad he got talent hey something
there it's not bad you guys continue
talking i'll i'll i'll bring it up and
you guys decide for yourself but but he
said they asked him i don't know why
they asked him at the ufc press
conference what he thought about russia
and ukraine he was like basically like
they knew they're gonna get a [ __ ]
thing these politicians he's like i
don't trust any of these [ __ ]
like i'm not going to go war for these
months it's like if they come over here
he's like he's like i'll dig my arkansas
i'll take my boots in arkansas soil baby
and i'll die for everything i love
dude i like how hard he wraps arkansas
he reps it hard i'll sink my boots into
arkansas soil like his just [ __ ] feet
are just sinking into the ground
good thing about iraq is they [ __ ]
their cousins like what i do
but he was not
just making this a direct quote from
brexit that's exactly what he said he
has on a shirt dude [ __ ] all this russia
so this song is called [ __ ] it's
called
arkansas
arkansas let's go
[Music]
[Music]
when i heard that tyler woodley song i
was mad at it i was like upset uh [ __ ]
yeah like you can't yeah yeah dude if
you're a ufc fighter you can't have a
song about how you beat everyone's ass
like it's two corners i don't know roy
jones
jr had a sick [ __ ] song but that's a
different time it was about whooping
full's ass and it was but it was dope
but it was about how roy jones jr was
the best and you almost forgot he had a
line about having all the [ __ ] in the
game too yeah
did you know they had another youtube
celebrity boxing match no they had
another one the guy you posted the
filipino dude he's the guy that does the
fake running right yeah that dude is
[ __ ] hilarious first of all but he
got hands no idea he could box he nice
bro he's real nice and he's like
he was uh he was showing up
look at this dude later on you see this
guy his name is salt poppy i don't know
his actual name salt puppy salt poppy
and i don't know what the [ __ ] she does
that's nice his name already is
hilarious immediately loved him i
thought he was cambodian
i thought he's from the states he's not
i don't think he's from the states is he
not i think he's like from uk or some
[ __ ]
i was uh i looked at this clip i'm like
oh [ __ ] people are boxing again like
youtube's celebrity boxing and i'm
pretty sure now that they've seen the
level of competition they're gonna have
to take it seriously or they're gonna
get clowned yeah but this guy saw poppy
he's fighting this other guy his name is
hilarious too but his name's halal ham
hilarious
i don't know i don't know if i don't
know anything about the guy but halal
ham is just a funny ass name and they're
both on the chubbier side okay but
bro
yeah that halal ham guy he had a decent
jab they're definitely the best
youtubers i've seen box yeah if they're
considered youtubers or whatever you
know but that dude saw poppy he for sure
has boxed for quite a bit because he was
moving so well no really when i first
saw who that guy was and then i saw you
post him it was like at the beginning of
the the pandemic and i just saw this
like
kind of chubbier filipino dude doing the
fake running and then he would actually
like box
with his homies on like the basketball
courts oh for real yeah so they were
like doing like fake sparring and [ __ ]
not fake but like you know just sparring
whatever and then when you posted him
and i saw him there and i saw the
difference from the first videos i saw
versus him now i was like wow he got
actually pretty good the funniest thing
about this dude is that he has this uh
persona that he puts on salt poppy where
he kind of just kind of yeah he's just
doing that
he kind of puckers his lips out
this full he's about to do a real boxing
match doesn't break character once
and he's doing it he's like doing it to
him while he's about to suck him in the
face
it was great it was cracking the [ __ ] up
how are you in an actual fight and
you're still in character dude what the
[ __ ] is this and the clip of hello ham
was like against the the ropes and he
was kind of like flinching a little bit
and this dude is doing his [ __ ] lips
and he's like he's about to and then he
cracks them and i was like oh [ __ ] this
guy is crazy he did this one sick ass
move where uh [ __ ] that halal ham
dude um the fact that he's saying that
name is hilarious but he throws a pretty
fast jab this full pullback counter
cross
right in his face i'm like dawg what the
[ __ ] is this who is this guy he's a star
bro my spirit animal yeah
i want to be him so bad
hell yeah this podcast is sponsored by
better help online therapy yes my
friends long time sponsor i love better
help i've been using it for a very long
time my therapist and i when we talk i
feel heard i just you know during
pandemic was kind of a rough time for me
and having better help especially the
way i was able to communicate with my
therapist was super easy just really
accessible and at the end of the day my
friends if you guys don't know all
relationships take work and the most
important one you can have is the one
that you have with yourself your
personal relationship with yourself we
focus on a lot of other people but you
have to realize that you are important
to invest in yourself therapy coaching
self-care whatever that it is better
help has helped me out a lot and i hope
you guys really do use it better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera it's a lot more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with the therapist in
under 48 hours my friends this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp but
geniusbrainlisters get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's p-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius you talk about it
like i don't wanna
do this but i feel like you really would
though if i have new knees let's go
mm-hmm also i've gained an absorbent
amount of weight in the last few months
but other than that i'm ready to go it's
an absorbent moment absorbing i haven't
gained any i'm still 220 something but
still i'm very very out of shape um i
was walking upstairs almost killed
myself yeah walking upstairs will do it
to you though because you forget to
breathe sometimes yeah
when you walk up the stairs and you wake
up
you're lagging
and you got to put your hand on the wall
for a second like oh [ __ ] there was a
kid do you know uh who named alex uh i
don't know it's really costly alex
wasabi
yeah yeah so he did a boxing match too
against the uh the guy who boxed logan
paul uh the dude from the uk kkk
ksi okay
[ __ ] did i say
so his younger brother
so his younger brother boxed uh alex and
alex one but alex has been training
boxing for a hot second
yeah but uh that was a little bit of a
mismatch like alex definitely put it on
him pretty bad it was pretty bad damn
see that's the whole thing about the u
well it's just like you don't even know
who you're gonna get matched up with
right is that is ksi's little brother
does he even box
he's he did a celebrity boxing match
against jake paul the first time i think
that was his first opponent oh he fought
jake paul yeah it was jake paul versus
uh deji when they first boxed that's his
name deji
yeah oh look at that i [ __ ] got it
right there
he actually looked pretty good too
yeah he fought he fought on some other
boxing i think we talked about it too he
fought another tick tock guy yeah yeah
like boxing tick tock guy that's kind of
cringy yeah because alex
alex boxed um this other celebrity match
that was at i think it was like ten
goose again yeah yeah yeah your spot
yeah so shout out tengoose
and he fought this dude that never boxed
before but he was bigger than alex but i
think the the difference is that that
ring was a lot smaller and the number
two is that that guy kind of just threw
caution to the wind and he just started
swinging yeah you showed me that clip i
remember that because alex is definitely
a better boxer but at the same time it's
different when you just have a gigantic
man coming at you and i think like he
freaked out a little bit and then alice
got clipped pretty hard and he just
dropped yeah if you get hit once that
changes everything especially when
you're like not looking and the guy's
running at you like and i'm pretty sure
alex just you know he got a little chip
on his shoulder from that and he just
got a lot better mm-hmm i think you need
that you need your losses you need your
losses
baby though
i lost once i lost not recently though
not recently who'd you lose to uh the
[ __ ] first rushing match i had i lost
the decision
yeah i don't remember his name how did i
feel did you feel bad i did but also i
knew like uh
i felt bad but i was like i could have i
could have trained more and like i i
would sound like chris sosa to me dude
this guy making excuses
shout out to chris dude
um but that was i think that's the only
one and then i've been jumped before i
lost those you've been jumped been
jumped before how you've been joining
what happened
what did you get jumped for
sucking dick now
you [ __ ] used too much teeth last
time bro
[Applause]
i was it was like in college at a frat
like some frat party i mean
some buddies got into a fight with
literally an entire frat
and uh we got good we got jump it was
like four of us what did you do why are
you pissing off
so diego so my buddy
got kind of in an argument with this one
dude and there was like a line it was in
pomona so it's like a frat house in
pomona and there's a line like i'm not
lying like 20 to 30 dudes like yelling
at us and my buddy diego's nuts and he's
like the first dude he had problems with
he was like if that dude i don't know
why he picked that boy i guess that was
the dude he has issues with but he was
like
that dude like everyone else is yelling
at us but he's like if that guy says
another word like another insult to me
i'm gonna [ __ ] sock him in the face
and he tells me that and i'm like [ __ ]
dude i'm like there's a wallet he looks
at him he goes
we're good man what the [ __ ] you saying
there's a wall of [ __ ] there's
like five of us and
the guy says one more thing and diego
just [ __ ] steps in boom hits this guy
in the face and they like swarm them
like world war z and they're just on top
of him and i'm like [ __ ] so i started
like tossing bodies trying to just get
to him and then i see my other homie
danny just
knock a dude out just boom and i was
like all right we're fighting and i just
started hitting dude just boom boom boom
boom then i got swarmed and i was up
against a fence and i was like using
this guy as a human shield like i had
him in a muay thai clinch and i was like
using him like this and dudes are
jumping over like trying to hit me on
the top of the head and i'm just using
this dude like this and he he like kind
of pulls guard on me he just pulls me
down and i land on him and he like puts
his hands up and he goes no no no no and
i just hit him in the [ __ ] page
he saw [ __ ] ptsd he saw the story i
just remember him going
no no no and i was like [ __ ] it boom hit
him and then i have a job interview too
bro and then and then i see a foot like
this like a foot coming free
and i put my hands up dude kicks me i
like kind of catch it and then these
like eight dudes were just stop like
kicking the [ __ ] out of me and i was
just kind of covering up and then like a
brief moment i just popped up and like
just like backed up and i had one shoe
on
and i was like did you ever get that
shoe back i did get it back but at first
i was just kind of backing up like and
[ __ ] like yelling like
and then uh
my homie geo was getting his ass
we all just got our ass as well and then
uh well yeah there's like 30 people it
doesn't matter how good of a fighter you
are then diego but diego choked that guy
out
that's all that matters
like i choked that dude out and then uh
we went to denny's after and had
pancakes i think cause
as you're telling the story i remember
back in the day on this dude's like
[ __ ] facebook there's a picture of
him
yeah getting like looks like he got beat
up yeah
and you guys were all like bloody and
[ __ ] we were like oh that's the story
yeah yeah we're like smiling like the
[ __ ] psychopath dude it's always it's
the funny thing is too it's always one
homie that always starts it off i bet
you're that homie bro no i'm not
i'm always the pacifist yeah i'm always
chilling in the back and i'm just
waiting and then something happens and i
just go okay i'm about to get my ass
beat now i just have to do it somebody
ends up with a pencil in their face
right that's different though this story
young child there was so when i went
back to sacramento it's so funny
there's one guy in our group that used
to always get us into fights because he
had such a [ __ ] short temper and he
knows me he used to call me his
conscience because i was the nice guy in
the group because i was a sweet little
dweeb you know and he was like hey am i
tripping or not i'm like you're tripping
just [ __ ] relax but there would be
specific scenarios where he would just
snap and it's just like what are we
gonna do here i guess we just have to
see what happens and i'm always getting
my ass speed for this guy because he's
always trying to pick a fight with the
biggest [ __ ] person on earth and it's
just it was always the worst situation
and the crazy thing about this
[ __ ] is everybody remembers
these stories except for him he goes oh
i didn't do that
i'm like how do all of us know the same
story
but you yeah you [ __ ] crazy person
we were hanging out last time i told him
i was like hey remember that fun fool
uh he so he moved to hawaii and he came
back but after he went to hawaii i don't
know what happened i don't know if he
reconnected with his [ __ ] simone or
tongan roots
but
he came back all like you know island
out but he also came back a little
thuggish
don't [ __ ] know why you went to
hawaii it's a very sweet place to be
coming back i need to start the holidays
bro he literally starts talking [ __ ] to
him saying like oh i remember when high
school used to [ __ ] bully me not to
me but to the other dude so he's the
bully man shy no [ __ ] [ __ ] now [ __ ]
your ass up and i'm thinking like dude
this guy's gonna kill you man yeah like
don't say anything to him he just looks
at me like this and i'm like oh [ __ ]
comes up double legs him and smashes him
to a [ __ ] glass table whoa in the
middle of a [ __ ] party dude wow and
just starts wailing on him and the dude
gets his ass beat whoa i didn't tell
this but i told the story on the podcast
before that fool actually started crying
well not the guy who beat us the guy got
his ass he started crying it's like
at this point you should probably just
die it would have been cooler
it would have been cooler if the other
guy yeah i bet you he was like please
just kill me he went through a glass
table bro oh poor [ __ ] guy funny
thing is everybody remembers the story
but him
wow he doesn't remember he doesn't
remember it he goes did i i'm like what
are you talking about dude that was
traumatizing for me
out of his brain that guy has crazy
anger issues yeah he he's super calm now
but yeah back in the day jesus he used
to have a crazy [ __ ] temper we went
uh to a high school once because i guess
somebody was hitting on his
ex-girlfriend let's see his current
girlfriend wow and then i was in a car
with him and then we were driving i'm
like where are we going he's like we're
going to go jump this dude i'm like i
thought you're taking me home yeah yeah
what is this did you guys end up jumping
that guy the guy found out and he never
he never so he found out a walking path
that he goes on uh to go home and then
somehow somebody told that dude and so
he decided to go a different way so we
just ended up just watching a sunset
together
the whole time you're like hey you
should probably see a therapist hey man
uh i don't think this guy is coming but
you need some serious help absolutely
that's a happy ending i'm late to bible
study
and i'm here to jump a single man have
you gotten beat up with this guy have
you gotten like in crazy fights with
where you were involved and you had to
oh i got beat up a lot be in a position
where you had to like fight down you
throw down with a gang of dudes i told
the story last time on the podcast where
there was one of the biggest fights that
we got into was um
there was this really big uh
like samoan dude right and i completely
forgot about this guy
but he when we were hanging out in
sacramento he mentioned so this was a
party where basically somebody tried to
crash uh crash this party but if you're
if we don't know you you're not allowed
to come in right um because it was a
very this lady by the way to uh she went
to jail for shooting at a repo guy
because he was trying to repo his car
her car and then she started trying to
cap this [ __ ]
attempted murder yes and then her name
is kim blasquez
but she was super sweet to us i didn't
she i don't know if she was related to
anybody that we knew i thought she was
related to my buddy sam wasn't related
at all
her name was mama wendy she passed away
now she's a little bit rip i love love
you very much but
these guys try to crash this party
wouldn't allow them to come in and next
thing you know they're like well we're
gonna [ __ ] come in anyways and they
would have to say to this one hot
tempered dude and next thing you know
i'm just sitting in the back everybody's
drinking we're like playing cards or
whatever and he's like shit's about to
go down and i just feel like they [ __ ]
that's exactly what i was like
what the [ __ ] dude yeah right right
this was the craziest thing that [ __ ]
happened
i actually forgot about this part and
this is the part that he the funny thing
is he can't remember specific things but
he'll remember things that i did that i
don't [ __ ] remember so everybody is
going to and this is not a smart because
so it was a guy with a it was a bunch of
dudes in the car but they're trying to
crash a party with like 30 people that
know each other
very very bad [ __ ] why are you trying
to go to parties where you're not
invited well i don't know i don't even
understand what the [ __ ] that shit's
about and by the way this party is like
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere so i
don't even know how they found out about
this [ __ ] so long story short with this
these guys get [ __ ] up this one
gigantic
tongan simone dude is literally chucking
people like jazzy jeff you can't fight
tom in the fresh prince just [ __ ]
fight tongans i don't remember this part
but he told me this he goes do you
remember when you were [ __ ] smashing
that dude's car like a street fighter
bonus stage
so i was like kicking in the [ __ ]
door smashing the rear view mirrors or
whatever just [ __ ] up these dudes
cars and then you can see the
then he starts laughing and he tells me
because do you remember when everybody
started pissing on that dude's head what
so one of the guys
kelly to do
straight up the main dude that was like
starting [ __ ] that wanted to get into
the party he got knocked the [ __ ] out
and then everybody just started pissing
on his head wow
i think i think that's better than more
brain trauma i think they were just
sterilizing the cuts and the bruises on
his face yeah it was a medical property
literally started they pulled down their
pants and they were pissing on the dude
did you join in
i don't think i did i think i would
remember that part i don't think i did
that [ __ ] that's drastic as [ __ ] yeah
they i mean piss on this fool's face
that's the 90s though bro that was the
last biggest group fight i ever got into
and i did not want to do any of that
[ __ ] it was so bad because people had
bats people were getting [ __ ] up right
never got any advice like that it's so
dumb to do that honestly it's just like
wow let's just chill you know am i [ __ ]
because i've never been a fighter no but
it was a safe bet for me there's like 30
people yeah you're on the winning side
you're not i wasn't his situation where
it was me versus a thousand it was the
other way around i've never been in like
a mob like that i've never like had to
had one enemy you know what's crazy the
boys were like let's get this
[ __ ] the adrenaline is insane oh
yeah the adrenaline it's i remember too
after the shoot was all over i took it
tired
he took a nap afterwards i got the party
and the adrenaline dumped it was that
mama
i just [ __ ] napped on the couch i was
so tired from yeah from destroying the
car by yourself
dude the adrenaline is insane like so on
the flip because yeah we were on the
side of like
for sure we're all about to get our
asses
like there was no possible way i would
have never engaged i've been like diego
you're on your own
yeah we had to like
you just see him get absorbed into a
crowd of people he just got eaten alive
yeah but i you know he just we had it it
made us closer it made us closer we all
took that ass whooping pretty hard but
you know we got we had one homie too
that was i'm gonna go back there and
[ __ ] burn that place to the ground
and we're like dude we just like [ __ ] it
we lost
hey man that's murder yeah
he was so mad i was like dude like [ __ ]
it we lost we fought
30 of
them let's go eat some pancakes my
lovely genius farts this podcast once
again is brought to you by i p
vanish we get sponsored on this podcast
because your continued viewership so i
want to bring you guys dope deals and if
you don't have ipvanish what is you
actually doing because guess what you
need to protect your privacy if you
don't have ipvanish by now i don't know
what you're doing you need the added
security because everybody is prying
into your [ __ ] that's why i use
ipvanishvp to make it easy to stay truly
private and secure on the internet
ipvanish helps you safely browse the
internet by encrypting a hundred percent
of your data yes this is no game this is
no joke you need to get this ipvanish is
offering an incredible
70 off their yearly plan for our
listeners with a 30 day money back
guarantee and that's like getting nine
months for free so yes i am not playing
get ipvanish 4.6 out of 5 on trustpilot
that's how dope they are so go to
ipvanish.com brain and use promotional
code brain and claim your 70 savings
that's i p v a n i s h dot com slash
brain i always when i see this scenario
i just picture you guys talking [ __ ] to
these guys and all they're saying is
their fat name is [ __ ] like alpha shaped
[ __ ] you beta hyphen nine six five four
said like yeah not chill man what's your
name what's going on semper fly [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] doggy yuck not fun dude so you
don't you'd be beefing with a lot of
frat guys uh you have a lot of stories
where you got fights with frat people
why yeah well there's like a i don't
want to like generalize all frat dudes
we should though we should but there's
those dummies a lot of you stink d-bags
you know like there's a lot of deeb are
you a part of a friend no because i
actually just made friends like a normal
person just make friends yeah you know
that's oh i'm i'm a portal fred david
that's not what it's about shut up what
is it about them tell me you tell me
what a friend there's actually some
pretty like cool frats where it's like
like academia based yeah and they're
boring
hey i like those guys right yeah i
[ __ ] love them yeah yeah but then
there's like the other fraternities
where they're like hey we gotta link
arms and climb this mountain for
brotherhood yeah right yeah that's crazy
so i was i there was yeah do you think
medical frats do hazing they don't do
that they i mean they do it's it's so
funny too because you put this iv in
this patient and now here's a syringe it
has aids
[Laughter]
when you're a frat they there's like
benefits to it so they'll have um these
other fraternity brothers who graduated
uh before them they'll pass down all
these tests and answers so they're doing
really well see that's cool so that's
why this connection the other side of it
too is that a lot of anyways a lot of
the frat people that i met you could
tell that they were the highest pinnacle
of a loser in high school and they're
doing this because now they want to be a
part of a group that where they're the
accepted cool ones they want to be more
of a like these friends kind of take
advantage of them they do sure you know
so they'll do just about anything
because they'll do these weird things
with like their sister fraternities or
sororities where they'll have like these
speed date date nights where they're
like oh you have to go on a date with
their brothers and then you have to me
so it's like the most losers creepiest
thing i've ever seen about it's weird
it's weirdo [ __ ] it's all weirdo [ __ ]
and it's like two like any anybody
that's trying that hard to be a part of
a group is weird i've never been like
that i've always been like just be let's
just be cool yeah but if you're like
yeah i want to be a [ __ ] brother like
dude you're what's up brother
weird
too
i made a joke about it but i'm serious
they had a link arms and then climb up
this hill in the middle of the night
why bro i'm already paying you money to
be a part of this [ __ ] thing just
give me the answers to the test and go
[ __ ] off yeah you can't just climb the
mountain we gotta lock arms over you
can't go drinking or something logistics
just chill i just have a beer doggy
what's going on do you remember i met
this dude
there was there was a dude in santa
barbara it was a black fraternity so he
came in like so people in santa barbara
would just walk in your house like there
was just no straight open to the public
your house your home your private space
open to the public these guys come in
they were cool as [ __ ] and we're just
partying having a good time just met
them 30 seconds ago we're taking shots
in my house um and he shows me his arm
and he's like look at this look at this
this is what i did for my frat and he
was branded like he had a branding here
and i was like i was like my face
visibly was like oh my why would you do
that
his face went from thinking it was
really cool to seeing my face thinking
that it was really not cool and then it
made him doubt how cool it was
because he was like look how sick this
is and i was like and then he was kind
of like
oh like he was like oh i made it myself
i made a mistake you should have been in
the hospital he left like
two minutes after that they just left we
were having a great time and then that
kind of he was like i gotta go he like
kind of he kind of took the wind out of
his face
and i was like damn dude right and i
have to go especially because number one
that's like some honestly some slave
[ __ ] bro we're all thinking yeah yeah
you couldn't you couldn't start with the
tattoo it was a hole with the tattoo
that brand too on the shoulder like like
it that should look gnarly i was like
i don't understand that bro i understand
brandon maybe some people will look at
that and go that's cool but i was not i
did not think that was cool unless
you're a shaolin monk that's the only
time i bet you i bet you would happen
too they're like we're all brothers he
goes yeah and he brands himself they're
like that wasn't a part of it man
you do too much down as [ __ ] you're the
only guy you're the only guy with it
brother what's going on i'm going up
well guys that wraps up this
genius brain podcast hey if you're if
you're the guy that brand yourself and
you're listening to this you're a
[ __ ] idiot just don't get any more
brands we all make mistakes you know
it's fine it's okay he was like he was
he was a cool guy i'm sure that was fine
not a good decision he's an idiot
you can catch pat at patrick.riley you
can see him doing his his stand up
you can catch nick at nick the ear he's
just about everywhere boom boom color
band-aid nte training dot com n-t-e
e-training dot com band-aid boy all day
and we will see you all next time
band-aid boys
you